[Music]
well a typical day starts with a hearty
breakfast once I've got that in me and
have some energy Cinda fun really begins
typical day for data analysts is really
involved in delivering on submission of
intermountain which is helping people
with the healthiest life possible data
analyze are some of the most creative
people in the world I think it's awesome
data analytics to me means harnessing
the power of big data you're taking a
sheet of numbers and figures and putting
together a lots of different puzzle
pieces when I look at numbers what I see
our stories it's art and science
combined in a very unique way that makes
my job really exciting you don't need to
be a mathematician to do my job you just
need to like to solve logic problems
there's pulling data out of a warehouse
which usually requires a little bit of
coding and then being able to turn it
and slice it and filter it from
different angles until you figure out
what's really making everything else
shift can I imagine myself in the shoes
of that person that that has that
condition and what are things that I can
do then to reach out to that person so
we do a lot of research to be a cutting
edge like state of the art facility
we're looking at select populations so
for patient has a general surgery we
want to find out okay what is the best
practice we're trying to standardize
protocols here what can we do to improve
their outcomes so we can shorten their
hospital phase and reduce their bills
things like that
Intermountain is consistently looking
for really good analysts I look for
someone who is willing to look for ways
that they can take data and make it sing
so you have to be a little bit of a
detective and have any quiz that is mine
I would recommend that they get a very
strong quantitative background with
statistical classes I mean you can start
with a simple graph of okay block how
long it takes for you to bike home from
school start with simple things like
that that apply to your life just don't
stop with your little games of
self-deploying
everyone will be here today we have
happened to misplace a sensor actually
I'd like to get an opportunity to
combine our supply chain products like
we can build any efficient easier to
mount healthcare if we had access to
surgical services data would we be able
to come up with appropriate use criteria
so I'm not just helping some CEO meet
his bottom line I'm helping physicians
make better choices about how to treat
people and people in my community even
though we sent the cubicle and crunch
numbers we have an impact on what goes
on day to day in a hospital we can make
a difference in people's lives this is a
great time to be in analytics we're able
to bring all of that data and knowledge
to bear on problems that we've never
been able to solve before data analytics
is beginning to touch every aspect of
people's lives and the people who can
work with that data will rule the world
[Music]